the movie surrounds a high school girl
named min son because of her appearance
she is frequently bullied in school by
popular kids her only friend is minji
but before knowing her in high school
min's son had no one to talk to for the
16 years of her life hence she created
an imaginary friend named inor who
manifests in front of her when she is
alone and needs a friend to talk to one
morning min's son is getting ready for
school while enor keeps her company she
is overly excited about nothing because
her guts tell her something wonderful is
about to happen today inor praises her
optimism but asks her to hurry as a good
imaginary friend would on her way to the
school min's son is approached by minji
they talk about a new comic that min-sun
managed to land the last copy of
surprisingly enough minson's favorite
character is not the hero but the
antagonist she finds the character
attractive because he is passionate
about what he does this resonates with
her real life as minson has a crush on a
guy similar to the villain in the comic
his name is hote the popular kid who
everyone is afraid of coincidentally
just as she is thinking of him he
approaches her and hands her a key ring
that fell off her bag this is the first
time a guy is being nice to min's son
and she is especially happy that it is
her crush hote asks her to be careful
and walks away when alone min's son
meets inor again he can see how much she
likes hote but doesn't comment on
anything about the guy min sun on the
other hand is over the moon positive
that many nice things are coming her way
later that day both she and minji meet
at a cafe minji seems to be bothered by
something but min's son doesn't notice
it they continue reading comics when a
group of three bullies approaches them
minsan knows they bring trouble so she
tries her best to mind her own business
but they take the comic away and refuse
to return it the meanest girl from the
group is momo she says she wants to
borrow the comic and keep it for the
next 10 years when minson speaks up for
herself they threatened to kill her on
her way home things start to get out of
hand but just then comes hote to min's
son's aid his father is a businessman
whose influence makes even the bullies
fear him hote beats up the guy in their
group and sends them all away he also
gives min's son his number so she can
call him if they trouble her again after
school minson is going through hote's
social media fawning over his pictures
after finding out what happened today
even inor believes hote has feelings for
his friend as they chat about him his
name flashes on min's son's phone and
she rushes to meet him outside when
asked why he called hote confesses that
he likes her and wants to take her out
on a date minson doesn't believe him at
first unused to male attention but as
hote leans in for a kiss her dream
becomes a reality minson closes her eyes
waiting for the kiss but it never comes
instead hote takes a picture of her most
vulnerable self and then makes fun of
her like the psychopath he is it is then
revealed that he never liked her and was
only being nice for a prank the bullies
join him laughing at min's son for
thinking that she had a chance with
someone like hote he is not just a bad
person but also a sociopath oh damn i
was joking but it's actually part of the
script he rules over the school and uses
his father's influence to terrorize
people for fun he wants min's son to
take on the responsibility of his slave
she must come to him whenever he demands
and he can do whatever he pleases with
her min's son is still in shock but she
knows her life is going to turn into
hell from now on moreover it is revealed
that minji was also in on the bully's
plan because she was threatened the
scene cuts to a month later minson
turned her phone off and hasn't been out
of the house since the bullying incident
she sleeps all day drowning in
depression her only companion is her
imaginary friend and he too is tired of
seeing her like that one day he
introduces her to the concept of revenge
the poor girl never thought going
against the bullies was possible but
enorm motivates her enough to do
something about her life in the
following montage minson changes her
lifestyle completely she manages her
diet and exercises to lose weight not
just that but she wraps herself with
tape and suffocates for hours driven by
the will to take revenge apart from her
weight she focuses on changing her
attitude and gaining more confidence
through several courses exactly a year
later min's son is a changed person she
is thinner and the most confident she
has ever been but she cannot help but be
nervous since it is the time to finally
face her fears the first person she goes
for is yong jae the least important
member of the bully group she starts by
hitting him and pretending to have
mistaken him for someone else youngjae
instantly falls for her charisma now
that min's son is conventionally
attractive and physically abusive they
flirt for a while before exchanging
numbers yangjae is over the moon while
min sun is ready for the next part of
the plan later that day hote notices
yang jae looking at his phone frequently
he doesn't allow any of his close mates
to do things without notifying him first
they aren't even allowed to be in a
relationship without his permission but
they put up with his demands to stay on
his good side upon realizing that
something is off about youngjae hote
jokingly threatens to kill his
girlfriend if he has one in secret hote
is deeply deeply in the closet minji
still works as a slave for the group and
buys things for them this time she
forgets to bring cigarettes angering
momo the last member of the group is
mina the kindest one of the lot who
wants to forgive minji hote registers
that she always interrupts him when they
are bullying people and warns her to be
careful when he is not around yongjae
calls min's son and they meet again
min's son is shocked at how differently
he talks to her than he used to the
change in behavior angers her as she
remembers how miserable she was because
of him only a year ago youngjae tells
her that he likes her but she rejects
him saying that she is in need of 1
million won and cannot be distracted the
next day yongjae sells his phone and
gaming console to get the money for her
min's son is taken aback but the gesture
angers her even more she says that she
will return the money in 10 years
mimicking their words to her youngjae
still doesn't get the hint though and is
shocked when she throws the money at him
and walks away he quickly stops her
asking her the reason she is rejecting
him minson truthfully claims that she
despises all bullies and he is one of
the known bullies in the school in reply
youngjae says he will leave the group
and change if it means that she will
accept him in the following scene minji
is again troubled by the group youngjae
approaches them asking her to go away an
angered hote inquires what he is doing
and is surprised to find out he wants to
leave the group just when things get
heated min's son comes to yangjae and
makes up an excuse to save him hote is
instantly alarmed by her presence but
thinks she is stunning to spite yong-jae
he is extra friendly to min's son and
even asks her for her number momo is not
happy about the interaction because she
is in love with hotei and they have been
in a relationship for a month now when
hote asks min sun for her number
youngjae comes in between and drags her
away he doesn't like that she interfered
in his matter but minsun hugs him and
makes him forget about it she claims to
be 10 in love with him as a joke so he
would work harder to make her fall
completely in love at night enor asks
minson if she is doing okay the change
in her attitude has also turned her
somewhat heartless which worries him
however min's son doesn't see any
problem with what she is doing and is
happy to use yong-jae for her own
benefit eenor sees how different she is
from a year ago and the story goes into
a flashback after trying several ways to
lose weight including the tape method
minson had still not made progress then
one day hote came to visit her worried
that she hadn't come to school in more
than two months he found out about her
little revenge plan and made fun of it
he made her believe that being thinner
or more confident will never change who
she is from the inside she will always
be their punching bag a loser that no
one likes the visit made min's son go
into another spiral of depression and
she ended up committing the unthinkable
during her funeral a miracle happened
and her sister sai saw enor for the
first time she used to live far away and
never knew what min's son was going
through upon finding out about the
bullies she made it her mission to take
revenge for her sister's death hence the
confident person who returned to school
was not min's son but her sister sai a
few days later sai meets hote she says
that youngjae is just a friend and tries
to seduce him she wants them to fight
and end each other without her having to
do anything to break them they exchange
phone numbers and decide to go out
someday sai then goes on a date with
youngjae waiting for hote to call her
phone in front of him she brings him to
his house and he tries to kiss her while
watching the tv the phone rings at the
right time and youngjae sees hote
calling her she picks it up and agrees
to go out with him the next day yangjae
is stunned but sai recovers by lying
that she was forced to give him her
number and she doesn't want to meet him
either youngjae believes her and grows
more hateful of his former best friend
he promises to get rid of hote at any
cost much to size delight in the evening
he calls hote in an alleyway ready to
hit him with a baseball bat but taking
him by surprise someone else knocks him
out before he does anything a week
passes with no sign of yongjae sai is
worried that her plan might have failed
after so much work she still has to go
out with hote and is terribly nervous
given their history momo finds out about
this on her and hote's two month dating
anniversary to apologize for forgetting
hotei gives her a golden lighter as a
gift still momo is not someone who lets
things slide that easily she gathers up
a few men and goes to teach psy a lesson
for hitting on her boyfriend the
interaction is cut short when sai tases
momo and strangely enough the guys do
nothing she leaves the bully with a
final warning asking her to never bother
her again similarly mina who is the kind
one in the group apologizes to psy on
her own silence her go because she was
never really mean to her anyway now the
only person left to deal with is
[ __ ] mcgee in the next scene we see
a fight between hote inor and sai they
snap each other causing everyone's death
suddenly the scene changes to a
psychiatric hospital inor is a doctor
treating psy for her multiple
personality disorder in a wild turn of
events it is revealed that hote and the
bullies never existed they were
personalities derived from psy herself
last year size disorder grew intense and
she turned into a violent persona
brought out as hote unable to suppress
the persona she killed her sister min's
son eventually she realized what she did
and was struck by guilt to avoid taking
responsibility she made up the entire
story about min's son getting bullied so
that she would be a hero in her own
story not a murderer who killed her own
sister all this time she thought inor
was her imaginary friend because he
would interrupt her dream world but in
reality he was her doctor in real life
he reveals that he has been able to get
rid of all of psy's personalities except
for hotei if she doesn't get him out of
her head she will be locked away for
life a few days after psy is informed of
this hote's personality disappears
completely enor thinks his treatment
worked and sai is given little jail time
considering her sickness in the last
scene psy is out of jail talking to inor
about life she shows him a lighter
similar to the one hote gave momo when
they last met hinore looks at it in
shock realizing that the killer in psy
is still present somewhere inside her
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching